all right we got one advertisement here
and of course i'm reading this
advertisement well after i did the whole
[ __ ] interview with the wonderful
adler family i'm in san jose right now
ah but ill boat boat me on DS me on de
san jose california boo boo boo me on DS
biondi's you won't get a hernia cuz
those things will hold your balls nice
and tight against you take to put them
on it'll feel like velvet you won't need
to get a hand job because your underwear
it's like a [ __ ] hot chicks hand
that's [ __ ] gross sorry whatever me
undies hey everybody if you want to
elevate you unduly you want to elevate
your underwear game to the next level
let me what level us you got [ __ ] stains
in your drawers I don't know where the
[ __ ] you're right you can elevate it
with me undies and the [ __ ] screen
just stumped didn't stop now I get a
punk type in my [ __ ] password this is
just not the way to do this you've
perfected your wardrobe but what about
this stuff not everybody gets to Satan
if you've been settling for store bought
underwear five packs I have something
that will change your life for the
better [ __ ] me on these what's the
first thing you put on a take what's the
first thing you put on and the last
thing you take up I don't want to know I
don't want to know you like that all
right [ __ ] keep your own goddamn
taking off and putting on a close to
yourself all right your oversharing [ __ ]
millennial it's your underwear make your
most important piece of clothing the
best it can be with me undies what is
the undies it's [ __ ] underwear have
you haven't figured it out it's just
seriously soft feel good undies
delivered right to your door buy some
[ __ ] weirdo get a man wants to go run
deliver and soft [ __ ] feeling
underwear looking that other guy in the
eye here you go the undies are signed in
LA and made from sustainable source
micro
modell modal a fabric three times softer
than cotton biondi softer than soft
luxury underwear come in an
ever-changing selection of classic
colors bold shades that you can put on
your balls and it'll be a safe place for
your nuts and guess what you can save
time and money each month with this
monthly subscription if you're not ready
for subscription that's no process no
[ __ ] problem you can still save this
because my undies is offering twenty
percent off your first pair just use my
special URL the undies calm / / and get
twenty percent off your first pair so go
ahead revamp your underwear drawer you
deserve it once again that's my undies
calm / / be undies calm / / now back to
the steven adler interview hey what's
going on it's bill bird it's time for a
very special Monday morning podcast
every once in a while have the special
ones it's not me Justin my jam jams
running my Yap in my old piece of [ __ ]
house that has a lot of character
speaking of characters we got some
characters in here today we have selling
her new book here that's about Steven
Adler drummer rock star extraordinaire
her new book called really amazing we
shall I don't want to make I don't want
to strike following equation you should
know good look house not even a cns
sorry don't get any interrupting all
right they even adversaries brother
Jamie Sharon organics here I feel like
went over their house for Thanksgiving
come over here there's just going to be
it's going to be a fun show this is
going to remind me going home for the
holidays so I'm sorry en advert new
books sweet child of mine which is
basically her story of having it's a
story of unconditional love between a
mother and a son and not only that it's
a story about how many mistakes a mother
can make in her relationship with his
son and believe why I made a lot of
mistake I got an offer a designer
fine this is the first time I've ever
heard admit to that it's true d oh god
only coming like dr. Phil hips you guys
hey let's bring some tissues over here
in the mid he did um Brenton did I
actually I you know I got believe it or
not in my podcast listeners know I'm a
terrible reader I can't read out loud
I'm really bad and I just got the book
yesterday I wrote things oh it's okay
there you go like I know we have to like
I got up to above page 75 of the book
and it's a credible just what I mean I
keep you know I can't wait for the next
hundred much say I'm stopping it just as
far as I guncles I read slow but I good
to things like your your day ago the
first mom hit Steven all right he's
laughing again we're in the arm nice to
me nemore in the way up they go to as a
handy arm the told her to page that had
were you a we because my mother here to
swim the kids I mean it was just you
spanked and then you moved up to the
paddle wooden spoon to be one of the
wooden spine all about the wooden spoon
all right let me ask you this Steven yo
your preference as a child was it the
wooden spoon please being random blunt
object never get the hairbrush I got
that does a hair of us a couple of times
of course the random object thrown
through the air ahead yeah that's my
sexy you your fall then you got a
beautiful head so you look really good
you're very handsome at me my head is
lumpy and you did the boss I'm not have
a good bald head ok so that's the thing
is you gonna fall you're praying you're
like I rented Lee you want to [ __ ] yeah
I'm gonna bother you a lot of rock star
they've got it hard you're yelling movie
stars rock stars dude to 21st and I'll
just kill me if you can do it do it the
amount of bands where there'll be five
people in the band and I'll be watching
it at home as a bald guy go there's no
[ __ ] way one of these guys didn't go
far no wait oh dude is a list of all my
long serious I have that disease knows
where I'm losing my hair it's called
middle-aged and it's going to happen to
everybody out there I just enjoy it wrap
it for me I'm 75 years old and I still
look good for an old back yes you die
you're looking right there you know
what's great about your book not only do
you get dealt the unbelievable
unconditional love that you have for
your whole family is it really made me
want to go get some Italian food
because it was so much of it talking
about i'm actually going to make
meatballs tonight when you were talking
about when early on but people haven't
read the book yet Stephens mom Diana
used to come by there their apartment
used to bring them food and everything
when they were struggling yeah well by
our studios you come get food this is a
great cook my mom is a fabulous because
of you know makes up putting it to upper
wear and bring it down grab our laundry
cool just watch on the table because
that's going to like a lot of noise oh
no I'm just letting you know all right
because that'd a vision everyone's you
know hitting the table guys damn King
not trying to put some restrictions on
yeah I just wanted people to hear well
here's a drummer Bill using oh my god I
wrote it on ebay go with the arms of the
chair that ok what is your what your
go-to dish uh you want to impress people
they're coming by yeah excellence
parmesan I make a very good XM parmesan
and make a very good lasagna I make a
very good sauce really I'm a good cook
I'm not bragging right but I'm you're
good you're good I don't a big part of
the book though and I'm a good cook so
that must have been so when you went
over there you got early on you got a
sense that the band was going to was
going to take off oh no nothing like
that oh no my studio day our bathroom
day in work and it was to disguise
didn't even go in Jenna I don't know my
thing by 10 by talking about the studio
that you do a guitar center that we are
used to live at well we lived at girls
offices but dollars are like a rehearsal
we always hang that and you know we
combine man's food I never understood
how they did that trying to make it as a
comedian you just by yourself and as bad
as it is you sort of this little
dictator and you can decide when you're
going to eat and blah blah blah blah
blah but if you're in a band you know
there's always going to be the late guy
the other guy doing this like I don't
know I said I always loved being part of
a team and when I was younger I played
football I love the way to when you get
together and everybody creates something
together let me in my band at the time
we we created sucks very magic and it
just happened have you read your mom's
book no I'm afraid to Reno
I already imagine what the pain I put it
there by reading it was actually that's
what you get in a book because I read
your book and you know I'm rooting for
you the whole way through obviously a
huge fan everything but now to get the
other side of a lot of those stories you
know the worry that I got to tell you
dude I'm not glad you put it through
hell man I only really put it to help I
I mean I didn't wake up every morning
through hell and don't forget that AC
double hockey sticks hey ll I did not
you know I'll didn't wake up in the
morning go hey how can I you know hurt
my mother and her my family right
friends no I it was I was you know I'm
an addict so I did what I did and you
don't think about it the const well I
became a dad of two months ago so now
I'm ringing this from announced a couple
months yeah so I'm reading it from a new
perspective and they are now I can be on
both sides rather than being the
messed-up kid but I already did that now
seen so if you want to tell people like
as you touch on part of the book like
those those feelings when you were
you're sitting at home I mean you're
always going to remember him as a little
baby and you know he's out on the street
and everything that must have you know
how the only now I ditching school let
me just let me get real quick Wow
described as the size of going on I'm
really starting to see this dynamic now
when he was growing up I didn't worry
about it because I knew where he was he
was by grandma's house but then I ok
there's a mistake right there I knew he
was at Grandma's house but I didn't know
what was going on when he was living at
Grandma's house that he would be going
out all night and going to these clubs
and but I didn't worry about because I
thought okay he's safe he's at Grandma's
house and what happened when you found
out that that he wasn't there well I
didn't find out till years later I thank
you how long I was a ditch school every
day you know they never does school
never even called her yeah this is like
the 70 years old amateur do it are you
going to liquor store 15 a guy
a cigarette and I'm buying a six-pack of
beer you're old enough yeah drinking age
was 18 right I was 21 what's 21 never
that means that we'll just walk in some
11 is do some cigarettes for digging is
bearing and today it was not seventies
were gray man its way with Alice I will
be wrong I'm telling you I want to tell
a story ok ok i used to i keep attention
so what do you have any that God do you
have any info cuz I'm got that far into
the book do you end up giving advice
because I think this would be an
incredible book for parents that they
were dealing with the situation that you
were dealing with I could never give
advice to anyone I'm not a doctor I'm
not a professional person or not a
psychiatrist or anything like that I'm
just even a vers mother and I told about
what it has affected me the things that
he did but if I wanted to tell people
what to do if i want to that i would say
if you have a son or daughter that's an
alcoholic or drug addict take care of
yourself and that took me a long time to
learn I mean years to learn stop
worrying about him that's his life you
didn't teach him to drink or take drugs
you didn't do that to him mine are you
doing doing oh no I didn't know that we
can do drugs are on their kids you know
I don't I don't know anything about that
you know about drugs or alcohol I didn't
I didn't know what was going on and but
I would tell people to go to al-anon
meetings go to AAA meetings to take care
of yourself so or even it's non attic
you would go to what try to understand
what you're dealing with exactly right
so you know what your friends or you
know your associate or whoever your son
or daughter is going to what up their
thinking and you go to the al-anon
meetings and you realize you're not the
only one and you just feel so much
better and our meetings are that that
was your experience well what happened
was my daughter lost Carolina Stephens
wife she would tell me go to an al-anon
meeting go to an al-anon meeting and I
say no I don't want to go there because
I don't want to hear anyone
else's problems okay but finally I went
to my first al-anon meeting which was a
few years ago and I walked in there and
I was I thought to myself do they know
who i am i'm so ashamed you know my
son's a gigantic is an alcoholic do they
know who I am well you know when you go
to these meetings are when you introduce
yourself you only say the first name so
they don't really know who you are right
and and I listen to what everybody is
saying and you want to know if like I
walked out of there and I said to myself
oh my god I don't have it so bad there
were such stories to be told people
haven't so much worse than me I couldn't
believe it and I felt good about myself
so did that make you go to more or I
went to boy yes yes I go to more yes
I've gone to a a meeting to listen to
what these drug addicts have gone
through their stories it doesn't hurt me
to do this i remember when i go to my
colleges is important I guess I I got
arrested for drinking and driving in
like the the late eighties and one of
the things that you had to go to a
couple of a meeting so I was concerned
like a god was going to be like and i
went there and that actually did make me
feel better like all right I drink I
don't not doing what these people do
yeah I always feel better going i was
forced to go when I got arrested in a
celebrity rehab him i love that i got a
restaurant show about doing drugs
because i had drugs on me I know how was
I highlight of my life I was a highlight
ok but so I was kind of I was I had to
go for three months every day I had to
get this paper sign and I'm so glad I
did yeah I have to go in in like the fat
their first couple days I enjoyed it I
goes one hour day hey did you look great
tank here you look great I over three
years yeah you are you look long you
know yeah dang clear right and
everything too we don't want it we have
life now we have a life this is a weird
al that I've means we come he needs have
joked about this something if you do
hard drugs in your 20s you have like abs
for life you guys are all in like crazy
shape nobody else may be down again I
don't know isohunt a 40 pounds
when I was drinking the last three years
before I got sober three years ago I was
drinking jägermeister and you want to
know something you could drink what age
not dude I said well I wasn't drinking
you know I was young right how'd you
know a few beers you go to rainbow and
you know get the long island ice teas
the Korean juicy buyers and but it was
like i went to this liquor store every
day but before I got sober three years
ago every morning I drank from six
o'clock when the liquor store open I
would be there sometimes before the
owner got there to open up oh hey man
how's it going yeah yeah how do you
think it's going i'm at the liquor store
[ __ ] before you jaja gone wait a
minute I want to say something I went
even is on drugs he was so skinny like
like a weed so tiny heroin crack will do
that to you oh yeah so leave I'm taco
bar or a jack-in-the-box tacos and ding
dong wait a minute hey girl I sir that's
des Eliza velvet or guy listen to me i
said this video I've listened you and
listen you cockeyed ft two years welcome
i'm so tired at dulles be silent okay
silence is golden agreement I don't mean
to me I mean why I don't know what
that's it clear the love I still hit a
lot now wait a minute I just want to
finish the sound go ahead okay when he
was taken he was drinking alcohol he was
heavy and i would tell everybody else
even never looked so good he's got some
fat annum now he's not so skinny it's a
pleasure to look at him I didn't know
that that's what I thought that was an
alcoholic of all the sugar it out I
didn't know that and it is sweetheart
you're making meals for people you're
encouraging all that I get that you know
so you're not look at all these are
wonderful my life yeah I just you know a
little on made you food yeah I with the
brush and no no no what it was please
our yeah its rate and what is for my
grandmother program wooden spoon over
she tried to hit me in the head with it
and I got the arm up the block and you
Vinny broke you broke it I regret and
then immediately she snapped out she had
this crazy look when she went to hit me
and the second it snapped she just went
she comes back to normal all he added
just get a solid hit anywhere on you
wait and you felt better I really I want
to talk about my kid sorry about Jamie I
used to going I used to I used to hit
him with the winds was just on the side
nothing Carol another Jeremy and all
over her yeah and so one night he talked
back to me so either I I used to wash
out their mouths word so so yeah now we
did you really do it make him stick the
bar at heritage you watch the face only
the time I couldn't you know I was truly
to do anything about him she's gotta
make a water break here hang on a second
and then also department so with Jamie
my youngest son he shaft me back so I I
didn't have the so bike I didn't get the
soap so I had to win spoon so I started
chasing him around the dining room table
I'm gonna get you you're not going to
talk like that to me I won't I'm like 10
years old yeah alright see gradual you
low to the ground you got a low center
of gravity so I got so mad I screw the
wooden spoon of Jamie he grabbed a
wooden spoon of starch is never going to
happen again mom I took a man atena in
the works pune Danny you can't have that
now wave it he can't have that as a walk
otherwise running after me with the
winds food and we started to laugh and
laugh and that was the end of the
windows I took away from when I put
under my bed and it was done you know
what I did my dad was in a fraternity
and he kept the paddle as a souvenir my
mother used to hear this would bit oh I
took it and I hit it I hit it in between
their mattress because I figured they
would never look there they would
ripping apart operons trying to find it
we're on to your genius even as a kid oh
yeah like the guy was out an accessible
my mother didn't have the greatest name
we're streetwise now I just call this
backwash I wouldn't hit him I just on
the thigh or the tush that's all my
mother didn't have good hand-eye
coordination or she gets so mad she
missed and she'd get your lower back of
the bar now about by accident I'm not
trying to indict I think the statute of
limitation ounce this one but in times
it's so different you know tell me your
parent or give your kid its back on
their toes or something and though
you're going to jail calling you and
what that way to get everybody this kid
for 24 hours a day like I do you would
smack him what anything but there wasn't
there wasn't all these video cameras you
know I just realize doesn't even say
where you can get your book at your book
is available at amazon.com once a time
once upon it once again I can't really
think that the Marin is available and
Amazon job times and it's also available
at um shut up books Marcus hey can I al
I'm all mixed up amazon barnes and noble
their bar ganna Adler's book sweet child
of mine is available at amazon com there
we go and if you're having go ahead oh
you know saying i'd like to say earlier
you're invited bill they signing march
29th at Barnes & Noble I'll bet in
o'clock over in the grove yeah a little
bit yeah I'm definitely swing by have
any Jamie movies in my brother long
liberties my brothers having all his
friends come out I had three friends in
my life I have three so you're down to
30 you need so I got two pairs of pants
seven churches 12 pairs of socks at 12
years on the world you get the the world
travel like luggage packing thing down
we're like I Dodgers is there it just
made like the size of a breadbox what
you're going to do a world tour you will
leave in your apartment for a year what
are you bringing two pairs of pants by
pjs a pair of sweats t-shirts underwear
sobs I love elevators to where i said i
want to tell you story about him going
on tour okay come up closer to the mic a
little bit one day he calls me up and
he's def is a
hotel and he said my you come on by here
I got some clothes I got some things I
want you to take home with you we're
going to play donington in England I
said okay so I go to the hotel and he
comes out of the hotel and he's wearing
pants that are slipped you know how that
in the 80s they had already know holy
geez they were still and also not only
that there were things I as push okay by
the tush he's a rock star we didn't wear
I know we're about Daniel and so no no
idea wait a minute so now i would have
good person let me stop tell this story
no and so now he's coming out and I see
he's wearing these torn pants I said
Stephen I just can't go on the Concorde
like that I said she had to dress
properly he says don't worry my it's
okay it's alright so a few minutes later
we're talking in a few minutes later a
great i'll never forget a great big
grade stretch limousine pulls up to the
front of the hotel and he says oh that's
my ride I said okay so he walks down to
the car and the guy opens the door for
him to get into limousine and he turns
around and looks at me says see my it's
okay but I'm wearing I said Lucy my
little my ass what I wearing you know
what does that like as a mother to have
a son achieves like that I'm very proud
of Stephen he accomplished so much in
his life and sure we've gone through a
lot of bad times but that's over with
now and I'm very happy right now or
where do we walk out her studio you're
so done wait i'm going to aid you ten
years went to walk out of here if I
wanted to hear any of your [ __ ] I
squeeze your head saying oh here we go
there we go well I'm doing that time
what was what your what's your favorite
city to play tube Amsterdam Amsterdam
for the obvious you're damn that's what
I'm looking for you
you know anywhere but I had to say
Argentina South America as a gray area
says he wants amazing a CDC's best live
video I think it's from somewhere in
South America are and the level crazy
that the fans are going was embarrassing
to me as a concert going like as a go
concert go I thought like I thought I
was bringing it for the band like the
whole place was going nuts tone with all
her place even if people understands
they're so passionate everything I earn
main concert when they went down oh [ __ ]
watching ironman calms down its insanity
it's just a whole River Plate Stadium as
a giant mosh pit what was that feeling
the first time you played and you're
sitting back there because it's drummer
you know you get to kind of sit down and
take it into you gotta beat what is the
greatest thing in my life is everything
I ever dreamed of and more how did you
play that night grain yeah I just took
it to the next I'll vessel oh yeah you
know he start small and work your way
after that's his dream is not to play
for five or ten people oh yeah it's a
paper you know five or ten hundred
thousand people what blew me away about
your plane was you know I was a
frustrated drummer before I became a
comedian and back in the 80s I'm sure
you remember like everybody had these
giant kits even if they were just plain
like a 24 thing and then you came out
you just had a little 4-piece kit I like
three it was actually really when we
started as a base there in floor tom
ride crash and a high hat and a cowbell
how did you like because the look was
even if you didn't play double bass a
lot of people had that second kick set
up without even a pedal I had that look
I had that look and then I was playing
with this other band in during the
afternoon and I got a call from / saying
that we're going to do a doll [ __ ] up
we showed the Troubadour on Thursday and
then he hoped us a show in seattle and
in London so I said he said you want to
go I said of course I want to go my bags
were packed my whole life which is
approximately you know 20 80 90 years ok
good so I think we got to get back to my
real huh so I thought I I was playing
with his other band
and I my mom's out does analysis a oh
god nothing to say no but anyway I broke
my bass drum head so when I went to
prepare gnr i said i'm going to set the
whole thing up i'm just going to use the
three pieces and it just worked want a
you got you got more out of that guy's
got out of the tent down is all i need
guys the credible drum part sorry so
backpack talk anyway I'm sorry I wanted
to tell them about the first time I saw
you play I'd love to hear that the first
time I sounds like I think was at the
Troubadour wasn't the truth we have the
Troubadour that one wasn't madam wash I
can't even I was outlined malice or his
realtor no I'm not talking about let me
talk for two minutes I'm so sorry with
all I know there was making a lot of his
mind I'm getting the wind spoon it just
making me feel homesick this is exactly
like comma get back into the kitchen
where you belong hi guys hey hey just
anyway it's the first time i saw him
play you're in it you are in the express
lane to heaven what are the express lane
to heaven watching you're dealing with
this [ __ ] you still have an older one
that having been seen yet sorry i
interrupted my policies guard I can't
talk you know let me talk anyways I
thought went to see him play and Jamie
was with us and Jamie was I think about
nine years old and we got a call from
Stephen Stephen says come and watch us
play I since it's a school night we
can't come he says come after dinner
just for a little while I said okay so
we drove one too huh we were living in
the valley at the time and we drove into
Hollywood and we parked the car down the
street I remember this and all these
boys and girls young young adults they
had on black leather pants and sheer
blouses and and their hair was up to the
ceiling and and makeup like you wouldn't
believe and those were the guys lord
knows a guy
mega Vega learn so we went into the
front of the menu and there was a
security guy there and he said I said to
my system can you please tell steven
adler his mom and dad are here brother
he says of course so Steven tells us to
come into the Stephen comes out he tells
us to come into the venue he said now I
want you to stay on the side of the on
the side of the venue I said he says
don't go in the middle I said go to the
side which trick that's where you're
safe and I say to myself what to be safe
what's going to go on here so a few
minutes later the lights go out its
pitch black in the venue and all of us
son Stephen starts to play and it's like
a 747 landing on my head that's how loud
it was that's how loud it we are already
so right away of course I got deaf well
I didn't hear nothing anymore that was
the end of me I was desperate about
three or four hours well you aren't
tough your dad yes I said yeah did I say
doc I said death and for battery for the
past three or four hours i was def on
the way home I couldn't hear anybody
talk and I said to myself oh my god I
can do this again it was too much for me
so right away the next time I bought
earplugs there you put in my ears I
didn't realize what was going to happen
I didn't understand it because I had
never done anything like this before
anyway so we were very proud of them and
so the second time you probably got to
avoids playing a little more because you
weren't dealing with the sonic oh yeah
let's sort was very very loud when they
start to play my favorite sorry when
they came there shows I brought my
grandmother oh yeah it is my 75 year old
grandmother Wow I got an NGO look jus
say about 43 yes and I said during it at
the barrier at the Troubadour you know
it's for safety and you know Jamie my
mom my grandmother stay there and
actually no she looks down at my
grandmas gone I like I'm playing on
stage and I'm looking around I looked
out and
front row there's my grandmother he's
standing right now I think right at
Infante your judge my Stevie I love you
Stevie and actions wanted a pair of
chaps you know the g string red gray
hair the last raid that my grandmother's
right there are two feet away I'm gonna
get out of there getting I am playing
org over there ok but my mother never
thought looked at athletes she was just
very Oregon me of course I know anyway
matter Jake honey I'm these kids and
grandkids 30 no she had 14 grandchildren
yeah but kids but it is great this lamb
you know like any of them of me as this
last is this your longest stretch being
sober three years that's a month before
I was eleven yeah first 11 years you
like you kill our killed it all right
don't you wish those years counted yeah
you know you don't know like what's the
longest you've been sober like I for me
it was probably the first 15 years I
just 15 years later my ID I agree 11
years that's amazing this must be is
this an easier time then Oh Deanna for
you now but now that he's you know look
at him I can finally get criticized look
at him I can finally sleep at night
because for 30 years every night when I
went to sleep it was oh my goddess does
the corner going to call the hospital
gonna call the police I mean what mother
could sleep when this but her son is out
there that's funny that's why I didn't
do any of those try didn't do any
Charlie Sheen jokes because I just kept
thinking when Charlie Sheen was going
off the rails and everything about the
tiger blood and all that stuff I just
kept thinking about his you know because
he Emilio Estevez that grew up watching
his movies and I love this holiday is
dad so I was just thinking like this
sitting by a phone waiting to get that
phone call that he said so everybody
just sitting there watching that train
wreck of a you know poor that he did I
never saw the humor in it but you know I
also know I didn't make it either so and
you know what there's a lot of parents
out there who have lost their sons and
daughters to drugs and they're just
regular people what their hearts are
broken now I I remember one story and I
think I told this story before about
this real estate lady
I was selling my condo in Las Vegas and
a real estate lady came to my house and
she looks at and she comes in the house
and she sees all these gold and platinum
records on the wall and she says whose
records are these whose awards of these
I said well they belong to my son Steven
Adler is the original drummer from Guns
and Roses and she said oh my god you're
mrs. Adler and I said yes and she says
can I come after i finished my client
can I come back and talk with you I said
of course so she comes back a little
while later we sit down the living room
and she says I'm going to say something
I haven't said in five years I said well
what is it she says my daughter died of
a drug overdose and I've never said that
before I tell everyone that my daughter
died in a car accident because she
couldn't bring herself to say it because
they blame themselves is like a shame
right Liz it's a shame is there's no
time to be ashamed but it was a shame so
I says some she says I've never told
anyone this unto you she never said 45
minute should tell she didn't tell her
family or friends she just tells to me
oh my daughter died in a car accident
but it wasn't true so she was able to
tell me because she knew that I would
understand what she's talking about wow
that's so important to be able to tell
somebody these things that you're
holding inside because resentment is one
of main worse things in for an addict
especially is resentment but refer
anybody you have resentment you can't
move forward with your life what being
able to talk about it and get out of
your system that's the first thing it's
like I mean this is having a many people
I talked about it in my book about when
I was I was living my grandmother's 12
13 14 years old and I say hey I have
this to starwood yep you know I live it
up real about fairfax and santa monica
you know hey where's in santa monica so
you know it's West Hollywood so you know
and there's always guys trying to
pick you up in the 70s but I used to
hang out at the rainbow and uh put a
starwood and stuff like that and one I a
good I got this older teenager I was
saying what drugged me and I get ended
up getting sexually abused you know buys
by these two that I was like 13 years
old and I couldn't talk about that
fergie forever but if something that was
deep inside directly that wasn't
acceptable for anybody for the last time
forget about it as a guy yeah somebody
almost like I'm 30 now that you can yeah
given any [ __ ] for that book you know
but that guy's butt good I once I talked
about that in my book and I mentioned
you doing when we wouldn't believe how
many people have come up to me and says
you talking about that made me be able
to talk about it I'm not talking one two
three I travel around the world okay you
guys you guys are public you're both
doing great you guys have to hit go
survivors do you guys think you're gonna
have a you know now that you're sober
and everything you could maybe you guys
will have a third book in you you know
what you don't have to hit them with a
spoon or anything or just you know what
you like sleeping an event I'm gonna be
hitting here in with the stories I mean
Meegan I don't have anything left in me
after just reads that way though I mean
you really put it out there so I got it
I told the truth about everything see
I've been writing this book since since
1984 every time I would see him perform
or we went like literally writing yes I
would write down notes on a piece of
paper saying well this is what happened
today and and she's good now she's one
of those people right so I yeah has very
nice handwriting and enjoys writing not
like me and you yeah no no I got with
you I can't even read my signatures I
whether they sit
dude and I when the game really so I
never thought about writing a book but
then a few years ago Jamie said to me
wow you have all these pieces of paper
all these stories why don't you put it
together for a book and I never thought
about that and so he got Larry spagnola
who is my co-writer he put it all
together Abraham yeah he helps okay he
was helping steven he he helps even with
his book and so we call Larry and Larry
said of course I'll help you you know so
he helped me a lot if well I mean it's
big so I can't say enough my fans they
know I don't read and if I get my hands
on a book and I can't put it down that's
basically the way it is with this one so
Jamie when are you going to write a book
man you like the only guy left in the
family right I'm working on my own book
right now don't peek at 25 okay bill
it's crazy because I've had at least
like four or five phone calls from
people calling me up saying I had no
idea your family was [ __ ] up and mine
is even worse than yours and dads and
it's unreal like people are really call
me up saying I have a secret to tell you
and like people are like rains are in to
divulge your secrets and every family
has one in my arms book I really want
this book to be a big success not as a
oh yeah sure I want to make some money
but I want to be able to help the rest
of the world I want the rest of world to
not have to hold on these secrets
anymore because like my brother just
shared a crazy secret oh yeah I was
Jesse area I shared a year so he wrote
it in his blood yeah my book in his book
the guy admitted that he was sexually of
alive write his book I remember had I
was like so as soon as you said that
it's within the next couple years he
kind of stopped to a heroin and crack
well big is that secret that he was
holding inside Ryan was able to let
though and that's what they talked about
when you carry mud you carry dirt like
you carrying a big load so all of a
sudden my mom puts out this book that
I've been getting some phone calls from
some you know pretty prestigious people
that I looked up to and they're they're
admitting that they have drug addicts
and disease in there behind their family
as well now you know what I found with
my comedy that there's a lot of angry
people out there
I've been working through my anger I
have a Porsche my fans going like dude
what you're not as angry like they're
getting mad at me because again I'm
along with a little happier I want you
angry man I still love you hey yes stay
angry do i love you know I would well is
it uh was it not a misery loves company
actually they want you angry great
disguises don't lose your edge haha yeah
it's like my edge yelling at other
people's mothers at a red light you know
I mean somebody's grandmother what am i
doing like this some you are speaking
for millions of people I have to bring
it down a little bit you know what it
means so whatever there's always a
couple people going to give you a rough
time so I um alright so we've got a
little more time left is there anything
else you know I mean what was it I'm
sure it's in the book but what was the
watershed moment will you finally saw
your son have like this breakthrough
where you felt like okay like he'll
actually like this time it might take
like that he's gone on 23 a run that's
incredible yes I I really never had that
like you say a watershed moment I just
I've always always said to myself okay
everything's going to be alright the
best is yet to come he's going to be
fine you know but so it's been like a
30-year battle up-and-down roller
coaster 70 and it's just like we always
have hope I mean we're the only two
people that have never left Stephens
life we've always been by his side oh my
wife and I think well he's a senior what
his wife and she never did a job or
Never but we've been we've been together
as a family this whole time the other
there might be times we don't talk for
like a year or whatever but we're always
there for each other that's the craziest
thing you guys ever tried to get him so
because I would literally at some point
the love for my brother be like I'm just
going to chain this guy to a trick
that's what I did I did that can't you
see by decorating is you can't do that
and while the rewarding because I work
to do the hell my friend Montana from
Canter's deli he wanted to chain me up
to his radiator downstairs in his base
manager it's not going to work as soon
as I get on when have more resentment
and I'm gonna go over and deep any
waiting while he sat down had a logical
conversation like steep listen I'm going
to change you this rail yeah mark can
hear me out hear me I'm going to chain
you to this race
oh yeah mattias book to all the pictures
that he took areas down Margaret I got
every goddamn thing you guys have ever
done about all time is wonderful i love
love ya i used to do so many crazy
things i would nag him go to a rehab do
this do that it's in joining no i would
go 2-2 about these out yeah p just shut
them up and i go and i didn't believe in
the next morning and there's 35 40
thousand dollars in the toilet because
once you give them the money and you
could lead 10 minutes later you don't
get that money back rehabs are the
biggest rip off and we are investment
i'm adding on what i meant exactly and
let you the owner yeah it's the biggest
ripa so but if you're the owner you're
making bent I call them revolving doors
cuz you're going to keep going in and
out and in and out and abutting fastest
rehab you had like you went in the
second of car drives away do you walk
like I didn't even get to the place my
friend Bob Forrest you know he works
with dr. drew you know I'm he put me I
planning to go to I think Michigan or
something like that and i got on another
plane and went to New York and it's only
two weeks that I went to some nightclub
some people recognize me that's you know
two to three weeks later I'm going to go
back home and Saigon playing went back
I'll never check in to see if you win
I'll call cause I did but I didn't like
in with them I just never showed up so
when your brother is your hero and you
look up to him and he's this big rock
star and the guys killing himself and
you watch them die and kill himself for
30 years your last hope is you gotta
kidnap a guy I plane to Los Angeles
right and that's what we ended up doing
and it just made it would just made a
completely worse and Fabregas forward
years later the guys alive and that's
all that matters is words yet today
right today to live he's healthy and you
know what he might have been dead or he
might have still he's still alive who
knows but that's all that matters don't
they ever bring two guys have any
resentment for the shed you went through
with your brother no no
I don't I don't have any resentment I'm
sure that because listen he was a drug
addict too of course I want to rehab one
time I've had my own share of
experiences but the one that got me high
the very first time when I was 12 years
old I me was my brother were you
thinking okay well i wasn't digging but
i was a jihad we don't know and gutter
guard every everything in half in life
happens for a reason it got me to where
I'm at today and if my brother was this
big rock star I wouldn't be the agent
the manager that I am I won't have this
amazing lifestyle that I have but so
resentments no of course I would have
loved my brother not to been a junkie
for 25-30 years but even if I wanted to
rock so I was John Key everybody you
know has the rocks or a movie star yeah
I'm sorry I mean everyday ordinary
average guy without the literature I
pick up the dog do when it sure when
it's your flesh and blood it's a little
different like you never give up on your
flesh and blood and so it's all talked
about in that book and my brothers book
too he has a chapter they're called Doug
love and I mean it's we can make a whole
movie on that one chapter give him a
milkshake in Las Vegas and he woke up in
Los Angeles and then he was held hostage
for like three months I could have been
going I couldn't I in prison I could
have gone to prison for the rest of my
life hey all I committed so many
felonies across the state lines kid
happy ain't over saying all this crazy
stuff but you know what I had no other
choice I didn't know what else to do
that's my last resort to try to help my
brother no I mean II don't happen you
know if anyone is going to be any help
after that yeah but see I would have
done so every we have anyways you know
what happened if they did they'd dented
at me I wouldn't have the resentment
that I did have towards them towards it
that made everything worse because they
kidnapped me I mean he wasn't there but
the kid people that had were holding me
hostage they're giving me better and
more drugs than I was doing on my own
okay they've already got if this doesn't
miss you want to read all of these damn
books oh yeah you have to have delivered
well I want to say one little story here
okay Jamie calls me up she's in Los
Angeles with Stephen and iron Las Vegas
and Stephen and Jamie qosmio says
Stephen to Los Angeles driving to Los
Angeles I said for what and he says
we're going to put him in a rehab I said
okay so Stephen and I get in the car
underdrive Israel and we're driving to
Los Angeles and he's every two minutes
he's poking his head in the back seat
and I know he's smoking I think he's
smoking weed but he's not he's smoking
crack so every few minutes he would go
put his head in the back of the seat you
know turn it around embarrassing I know
you're in the bed and so and you're not
aware that he's sitting right night yeah
I'm thinking smoking weed so I could say
to stop smoking the weed stop it i'm
driving the car I don't want you to
smoke in the car I told you not to smoke
and lo and behold he was course he's not
going to stop he's not gonna listen to
anything I say and we're about an hour
out of Los Angeles and all of a sudden I
didn't know where I was well and I've
driven this Ralph a hundred times or
more and all of a sudden I said to Steve
and I said I don't understand where are
we why are we here I don't get it I
stopped the car and he and he said and
he says don't worry i said i don't know
how to get to Los Angeles I said what
should I do he says don't worry mom I'll
guide you I said on one second apparel
rocking agate okay go straight ahead and
we go on a freeway their way why did why
Tina I will hire off in his car I know
it's that next to somebody doing crack I
people doing it on my stoop when I lived
in New York huh I walk around her but I
wasn't in the net with everyone I on
cracks yeah I want you
damn I hey I'm another but I didn't want
to do anything I don't know I didn't
know what happened to me I couldn't
understand it because I never I never
got like that but all of a sudden my
brain went dead I couldn't see literally
literally get numb and he's and believe
me when I tell you he guided me to
exactly where I wanted to go even if
he's on crack or cocaine or whatever the
hell he once you get out of 10 you're
all set you get lost Lord a new money on
this stay wherever you're going you know
every where you're going if I wouldn't
didn't have that drug i would have been
lost to all every day a big head ok now
i know where to go let's keep going
we're Jewish family how many Jewish
families could say a story like that
there's ass here a lot ok no probably is
well there's a lot more but we don't
know how not only all the stuff that you
guys are putting out there in your books
will will have the same effect you have
when you talked about how you're
sexually abused and you're talking about
how you dealing with the Sun that's
battling addiction I got to tell you
everybody listen out there the book is
phenomenal it's called sweet child of
mine by Deanna Adler and you can get
that on amazon com and if you want to
read the other side of Stephen going
through it you can read his my appetite
for destruction sex drugs and guns and
roses that's also available on amazon
com I can't thank you guys wait a minute
me so much I want to say i want to say
one thing you can also find it at barnes
and noble you can find it on kindle and
if you're um if a foreign country all
around the world you can find it on Book
Depository and please if you're in the
neighborhood a March 29 at 7pm go to the
Grove and I'm going to have my first
book signing at Barnes & Noble and I'm
very excited about it and I'd love to
meet you come on I can't top that any
day you go yeah ads are Stephen King
thank you guys so much for coming on for
a lil man I always and thank you guys
for listen to the special edition of the
Monday morning podcast I'll talk to you
guys again soon I don't know what we're
gonna put this up all right